there are ideas that are a twinkle in
somebody's eye there are about five
years out I don't really believe too
much further out than that because
actually with the best will in the world
you will have something that you don't
know about will change your mind for you
so yes with what you know now you've got
an idea what you would do in five years
time it truth be told that what you
think will happen in five years time
won't so events will change you where do
you start
often it all starts before we ever get
into play so somebody will design a
consumer device and they'll designing it
had a you know a beautiful an iminium
case with some holes drilled in it and
they'll analyze that and they'll say
right for this not to get too warm to
the Ute to the hand because people don't
like warm hands we can dissipate X watts
so that's the number you start with then
you subtract I mean you say all I want
this beautiful new screen and it's got
to have 16 K resolution or whatever it
is and it's got to have these colors and
that's going to use this much power and
they say oh well of course these days
people download lots and lots and lots
of stuff so we need this much memory
that's giving you so much power then
we've got to connect that up to some
staff that's going to use some power so
somewhere down the line I get the dregs
that's left and they say right this much
power what can you do what can you do so
the CPU group will get given a bit and
you know the interconnect boys will get
given their bit and we get given out a
bit per say graphics or video or
whatever it is and so yeah I get a
budget and of course like all budget
discussions you argue you know in you
negotiating you say I can't do it for
that I need this and they say that's all
you're getting and a bit of horse
trading takes place is that space as
well as power is that so depends who you
are if you're building a super phone
silicon space is almost no object it's
it's money so it used to be there was a
constant in the industry ten cents per
square millimeter of silicon tested
functioning packaged out the door in
millions quantity 10 cents per square
mile
nobody knew why just always was it's
actually gone up
as the modern processes in the last two
processes that's gone up quite a bit but
essentially it's money silicon area is
money but if you're building a real hero
phone then I won't say money's no object
but it's it's one set of criteria if
you're building a mid tier phone money
is everything
and so they care much more about how
much we can do in X square mil and
actually that ends up with two products
so you get one product roadmap that goes
how much performance per what and how
much for the other product roadmap is
how much performance per square
millimeter and of course those two
overlap a bit but essentially the hero
phones are all thermally limited so
they're different companies different
manufacturers that will have a different
power number but essentially they'll say
what can you do in a watt or what can
you do in 700 milli watts or what can
you do in 1.5 it's because they're
making sufficient margin on it that the
amount you spend on the silicon is
easier whereas when you're shipping us
you know a serious shipper of mid-range
phones could be shipping some hundreds
of millions of these chips you know you
can imagine take a hundred million and
multiply it by 12 cents a square mil and
you know sooner or later it adds up to
real money so they very very much care
so every single scrap of silicon they
can save is resolutely absolutely the
margins being worked on these days in
their in that area of the market very
very tight we've had standout Rao's
about fractions of us it's quite
millimeter it's this grown-up it's a
real grown-up game you know there are
people as I say making 200 million chips
you multiply that by 0.3 of this grand
mil that's their margin gone so yeah
it's a very very tight game so that's
where it starts then that gets handed
down to us internally
and say well what can you do and it's
right okay so efficiency measured two
ways that efficiency is absolutely key
to everything we do it because if you
weren't doing it efficiently you
wouldn't need a GPU at all so the only
reason you're doing something on a
graphics processor is because it's more
efficient you know try not to forget
that and try to make it as efficient as
possible and then you say well that's
all well and good but what actually did
you mean by do it and of course it
changes year on year so graphical
content gets more complicated so the 3d
games get more complicated user
interfaces change as well the way people
want to do those and actually those two
are almost completely separate tasks now
a GPU that's good at UI and a GPU that's
good at 3d gaming are almost different
devices so you have to Schmeer between
the two to make sure they're both being
done right and so we have people crystal
ball gazing and say right but if you
start designing a GPU now it's going to
be in a consumer device then I think the
content that it's going to intersect
with is going to do this so we better
our GPU that's good at doing that okay
so right we're going to have to change
the way we do X so this units gonna be
ripped up and start again oh that you
good news that units okay so we won't do
the whole GPU but this gotta be
ripped up and so there's a whole bunch
of what is go on there and then clever
people go away and say well if that's
the case if you give me this set of
assumptions rather than that set of
assumptions than I would design it in
this way and then they go away and
design it they they sit around
scratching their heads and working on
whiteboards and you'll see all of these
offices at more more whiteboards and you
could possibly imagine I'll clean mine
specially from this interview
then they'll model it they'll actually
write a computer program to model how
this would work start get an idea of
what's efficient was not efficient then
they would probably prototype it as
hardware and then the whole process of
simulation stars to
measure its efficiency so you know how
much power would it use how big would it
be how fast would it go and usually as
because this is engineering not physics
go around that loop you know repeat and
repeat until finished and of course it's
never finished
eventually the engineering manager says
boys were supposed to ship this next
Thursday you know come on it's not
missing the mail finish it finish it
that's good enough let's get it out of
the door I'm smoothing over some of the
cracks you know it's never worship in
the next Thursday it's you know we're
shipping it in six months time you've
got to stop tinkering because we need to
spend that six months validating it so
you obviously are adding in features as
much as capabilities do you ever have to
take old ones out yes but it's very
difficult because people say oh well I
just want it to be better
I only ever want it to be better at
everything than the last one and you say
well I can make it better at this but if
I could throw out this feature or make
it worse at that feature then you know I
could do a much better job on this thing
you really care about and of course
manufacturers are usually very very
reluctant to do that because they said
well I don't know I think I might have
customers who are relying on that and I
genuinely don't know
so deprecating old features is hard we
get there in the end it's really
if you just have this plan here and want
to execute it without the automation
it's really really hard it takes a lot
of experience and even then and then
those aha she found oh yeah it's also
worth saying that - tend to work in cool